[Musique]
philippe pierre-charles bonjour bonjour
à tous et merci d'être dans ce studio ce
matin pour répondre à nos questions donc
vous êtes membre est pour ainsi dire
porte parole du liant nage pour dépôts
liés matinik alors c'est un collectif un
citoyen regroupant des associations des
syndicats des militants politiques aussi
et puis des citoyennes et des citoyens
et des agriculteurs
il est plus des socioprofessionnels plus
ou moins directement concernés par les
questions de pollution notamment à la
chlordécone et les algues sargasse et
aux algues sargasse alors vous aviez
appelé à une grande mobilisation je
reprends votre terme du liant nage pour
dépolluer matinik à une grande
mobilisation la semaine dernière le 15
juin dernier
effectivement il ya eu une manifestation
dans les rues de fort de france
mais la mobilisation elle n'est toujours
pas massive
philippe pierre charles comment comment
expliquer que vos appels justement ne
soit pas largement entendu encore une
première petite chose je suis le dépôt
de parole nous sommes un mouvement très
horizontale et il y en a autant de
pottal que deux personnes participant
régulièrement aux travaux est capable
d'expliquer nos positions à vrai dire
nous avions deux aspects que cette
mobilisation d'abord lavés avons
rassemblé des méthodes des militants et
des personnes intéressées
bon il ya plus d'une centaine de
personnes savaient personnel prêt pour
qu'ils ont discuté pendant trois heures
de temps pour faire le point après une
année de
de travail est bon le lendemain nous
avions cette manifestation pour environ
200 personnes dont nous essayons
probablement plus mais nous notons quand
même une chose c'est que ça s'est fait
sans mot d'ordre de grève
joe au matin ou quand même beaucoup de
gens travaillent
ça a peut-être limité et puis autre
chose qu'il faut dire franchement aussi
c'est que bon trop de personnes
considèrent qu'un bon ben il y un âge
cas de polio matinée cabano et cadets
foule les revendications lors que ça
roulait et bio bon ça ne fonctionne pas
comme ça c'est à dire que le lyannaj
fait un travail considérable mais il
faut que la population semble beaucoup
ça doit aller au delà du soutien moral
il faut aller au delà c'est pas années
un vrai coup de gueule la radio
bienfaits des laïcs lenny est formation
ça c'est des sandales arias il n'y a pas
d'autre de méthodes comme sabour
peut-être que la prochaine étape il
faudra mettre les moyens en terme de
grève google déjà soit libéré je ne sais
pas mais on va en discuter
choisir un autre jour aussi qu'un camp
vendredi peut-être ou le vendredi
c'était le soir bray puis le lendemain
c'est là maintenant ça me dit bon voilà
quoi bon
il est vrai que celui en âge il est né
il y a
à peine un peu plus d'un an il ya comme
un air de forum social que nous avions
fait et qui nous avait permis avec cette
diversité d'organisations de définir une
4 from 52 rom indications et à la suite
de cela nous avons dit bon qu'il faut
transformer ça en mouvement durable et
ce qu'il y ait ce qu'il ya de positif
dans ce set mobilisation de 14-15 j'ai
c'est que bon on a là la preuve que le
mouvement et durable beaucoup de gens
prédisait que oui on sait pas et non
pendant une année
il ya eu du travail nous avons fait des
rencontres d'information de
sensibilisation dans une dizaine de
villes de martinique
nous avons rencontré les militants de
deux organisations politiques
le bpm et les ja oui mais fait du pierre
charles c'est là le hiatus un petit peu
c'est vrai que pendant un an vous avez
pris vos bâtons de pèlerin pour un
couple en quelque 106 vous expliquez
vous avez fait un peu pâle au tour de la
martinique mais vous êtes allé expliquer
des choses présenter vos points de vue
et entendues dans plusieurs communes
vous continuerez mais bon çà çà çà vous
diffusez mais on a l'impression que ça
n'influence pas au point qu'il y ait une
mobilisation populaire massive
effectivement alors en dehors des
dispositions pratiques auxquelles je
faisais allusion peut-être faire une
mobilisation plutôt en pleine semaine
quand week-end enfin bon voilà en dehors
de ça comment faire qu'au delà de la
prise de conscience justement bien les
martiniquaises et les martiniquais en
tout cas ce qu'il souhaite à y
revendique est vraiment dans la rue par
rapport à ça alors on va revenir sur
votre parce que ce qu'il faut noter
c'est d'abord qu'il y a
une progression bon il y avait une seule
organisation politique officiellement
dans lianda et c'était le grs bon
actuellement le pays a indiqué yves à y
adhérer bon le ppm pour le mans on
discute beaucoup puisque je vais
rencontrer
nous avons eu aussi le cncp prennent
très populaire qui doivent y travailler
à avoir des relais par exemple de
parents que se dit miku 2 à ce niveau
cela progresse or aujourd'hui c'était
une soulte yeux qui est absolument
incontournable et a bâti le moment où il
ya la volonté à partie au moins où le
message progresse bon nous sommes
certains que nous pourrons relever ce
défi parce que c'est de cela qu'il
s'agit
nous avons affaire à la plus grande
catastrophe que la matinée qui a connu
depuis les houssen 1900 bleus
catastrophe sanitaire catastrophe
écologique catastrophe économique
mais ça serait tout le monde à tout le
monde à ça à l'esprit tous les salaires
peut-être le prix bonne chance un petit
peu abasourdi pas ça qui peut et anisé
par cela et s'imaginent que on ne peut
rien faire et s'imaginent que le mal est
fait et que on peut pousser un goût le
nom ça fait des années et des années que
le travail se fait bon il y à une année
à peu près que c'est un peu saoul tués
de manière collective et et plurielle
bon c'est des éléments qui sont
importants et qui allant très bien votre
interlocuteur alors je sais pas si on
peut désigner en ces termes parce que
c'est peut-être aussi celui sur lequel
vous vous tapez c'est le préfet en tant
que représentant de l'état le professeur
oui le préfère en tant que représentant
de l'état et du pouvoir politique
actuellement en place alors il ya un an
vous avez remis une plate forme de
revendications 52 points là aussi est ce
que c'est pas trop même si on sait que
le problème est crucial
mais bon c'est voilà c'est ça fait
peut-être un peu de confusion quoi dans
ce cas nos plateformes problème pour les
apps de multiples aspects sanitaires
sociaux économiques environnementaux et
qu'il faut tous les traités bon nous
sommes néanmoins conscient que bon il ya
peut-être une chronologie d'un la prise
en compte des choses mais il faut poser
tous les problèmes et puis il faut
s'accrocher un certain nombre de choses
qui sont qui sont essentiels et qui sont
absolument urgent at il est urgent que
cette fameuse reconnaissance des
concerts comme maladie professionnelle
liée au corps du bon ça fait des années
qu'un bon monsieur macro est venue
rappeler bon comme et il nous réclamons
ça non il ya des procédures qui existent
pour que des terres en friche soit mise
à disposition agriculteurs et
agricultrices sans terre ce qui
permettrait 10 ans yeux ces terres
présumés cinq lors des connes de faire
les les cultures vivrières qui sont
indispensables à l'alimentation de la
population bomb est louée clamant que ça
se fasse
mais alors on n'avait pas de réponse du
préfet manifestement il ya un an vous
enfin suite à la remise donc de de cette
plate forme revendicative vous agace y
ait un petit peu là encore dans dans une
interview précédent là la mobilisation
et la tenue de la réunion à la maison
des syndicats
vous vous agace y est à ce jour les
réponses que la préfecture a apporté à
notre plateforme de 52 points de
revendications sont insuffisantes
vous estimez que les réponses sont
insuffisantes aucune politique sérieuse
n'est mise en place pour intégrer des
problématiques je reprends vos propos et
donc là vous avez un peu simplifié
finalement la présentation vous avez
vous venait d'adresser une lettre
ouverte au préfet la martinique 1
alors l'appareil il ya une série de
questions que vous posez par exemple
quand seront effectués gratuitement les
analyses de sang pour les personnes
exposées aux risques quand
disposons-nous d'une cartographie
complète pour les agriculteurs et pour
les jardins familiaux enfin ya une série
de questions comme ça et puis bon voilà
quoi
quand accepterez vous en tant que
représentant de l'état de négocier avec
les organisations de la société civile
tels que votre lien âge c'est à dire que
finalement le le préfet ne vous
considère pas ils n'apportent pas de
réponses qu'est ce que le préfet et dont
paris quelque part un écouter avec ce
gouvernement avec cet état ceux qui le
dirigent
il y a les effets d'annoncé qui sont
faits et puis il y à la pratique ça se
voit dans cette nouvelle mais là ça se
voit très clairement
monsieur m'a convié à martinez qui est
dit qu on ce qui a un sens élevé au
chlordécone et que l'état va prendre ses
responsabilités bon nous prenons à
témoin la population et nous lui
demandons est ce que l a le sentiment
que l'étape prend ses responsabilités
bon face à cela bien il n'y a qu'une
solution que nous voyons c'est de
protester de ceux de se mobiliser et de
créer un rapport de force ce qui
fonctionne dans la vie réelle concrète
c'est que les gens qui sont à l'origine
des problèmes
il sera confronté à une mobilisation
sérieuse pour les pour les résoudre
il faut conclure donc ça veut dire que
vous continuez le combat la relative
faible mobilisation du week-end dernier
ne vous décourage pas non c'est une
bonne mobilisation c'est une
mobilisation qu'on veut plus forte mais
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
positif
d'original parce que ça rassemble
certains nombres de de suture et j'ai
dit que dès demain mercredi à 18 heures
nous nous voyons à la maison c'est des
canaux invitant tout le monde à venir il
y aura la présentation d'un film qui
s'appelle les sentinelles qui est
extrêmement intéressant sous la question
des pesticides en général et du combat
pour ça et après cette prise de après 7
heures ce visionnage de ce film death un
tunnel nous allons discuter encore halak
celles et ceux qui viendront pour
continuer le combat il n'y a que cela
merci de vrai merci philippe pierre
charles membre du collectif lyannaj pour
dépolluer matinik bonne journée à toutes
et à tous